Now let's do a quiz on the relationship between
dependencies and hazards. Let's say that we have a
three-stage pipeline, where here we are fetching and encoding
the instructions. Here, we are reading the register inputs that
we need and doing the ALU operation. And here
we're accessing the memory and then writing the result
to the register. For an ALU operation we just
write to the register. Let's say that we have these
four instructions The first one is producing R1, and
the next three are using it. And I can
tell you that these three dependencies are the only
dependencies that exist in this program. The question for
you is whether there is a dependence from the
add to this instruction, and whether that dependence is
a hazard. Put a check mark into these six
boxes, depending on which one has a dependence, and
which one of these dependents is a hazard.